[Music]
okay we're just coming out of one called
what men want this movie was made in
association with Det and it's about this
woman that works for this agency that
represents sports celebrities to help
them merchandise a product so they're
like their little side gigs and she ends
up going to this psychic that gives her
some kind of tea and she hits her head
later on while she's partying and she
gets this the ability to hear what men
are actually thinking and it causes a
bunch of trouble and it's pretty cool
who I thought was hilarious what you
think this is actually yeah it's kind of
like a gender swapped version of what
women want which is Bill Gibson was in
it it came out a really long time ago
yeah this one I think was much funnier
it was hilarious yeah it's just like
okay like when you can hear what dudes
think which is like seriously it's like
my worst nightmare but she at first is
like at first she's like oh my god
that's my worst nightmare but then she's
like oh this can help me like get ahead
because she knew you know she worked it
was like all these bros and they were
trying to like screw her over behind her
back and stuff like that so she found
all this [ __ ] out but things spiral out
of control as they do and led to like a
lot of really funny situations also kind
of a sweet ending table like she could
have learned something yeah she tries to
once you realize is that she can you
know actually hear what men are thinking
she tries to go back to the psychic and
get her to reverse it and a psychic is
like not you realized that this is a
great opportunity for you whatever and
the psychic was played by Erica baddo
who is I believe a singer yeah yeah
that's she steals every scene she's in
she's knocked out of the park she's
hilarious they are like a little bit in
the trailer but she's in it a lot more
yeah and if you stay like during the
credits these are the credits like they
have like little vignettes like
are like giving psychic readings to like
the other characters yes making money
off of people so yeah like like
everybody and this is funny
yeah but yeah I think she's like yeah
and she kinda like boobs got a really
good really good sense of humor it's uh
I would say you know the format it's
it's a chick flick but not really the
humor is just universal you don't mean
that
yeah it's you know guy I watch it you
know and there's guys back in there
laughing you know there was just
hilarious yeah I don't even know like I
guess yeah I guess I can say like oh
it's kind of a chick flick but it's a
woman and her problems and all her
friends and kind of and problems in you
and there's the this the the humor is
very dirty from a woman's point of view
you know but it's hilarious
yes yeah yeah I don't like a lot of
comedies but I thought this was yeah
this one you know it's kind of a base
over the past two or three three months
this is kind of a breath of fresh air it
didn't you know it was kind of
surprising because lately some of the
stuff that supposed to be funny wasn't
funny yeah this was pretty fun or it was
a tame kind of funny yeah this is pretty
well I liked it this was like a raunchy
yes Roger is funny that's always it was
a good it was a good spirited movie you
know it was kind of a feel-good movie
yeah yeah
okay we just got done I'm seeing one
liam means call what was it called / -
yeah we would do we would normally do it
there in the theater but it's really
crowded in there so for a Monday night
yeah so we're doing it out here in the
parking lot the cameras everywhere
okay this movie was a basically
basically a revenge flick yes a pretty
much the same same premises like
punisher or Deathwish guy uh guys son
get works at the airport he gets killed
by some organized crime organized crime
group and he goes he goes and tracks him
down and tries to you know kill the guys
who killed his son and he's even wants
to take out like the gang leader - and
his brother helps him because his
brother is a gangster so he get you know
he helps him and what he does is he
inadvertently sets off a gang war where
it's a bunch of organized yeah so
there's all these criminals killing each
other because they don't know that it's
him that's killing some of them but
really what made the movie kind of kind
of unusual is that it was you want to be
honest review lament what made it what
made it unusual is that it started to
become like a comedy well I expect that
yeah if you've seen the trailers for
this cuz they've been showing the
trailers a lot like it's a theaters I
think I've seen them on TV and stuff
like that - the trailers kind of make it
look like I guess they're trading on
Liam Neeson and being like in the take
in movies and like those are really
successful like you know kind of revenge
action kind of flicks so I think the
trailer kind of tried to hit that angle
but this is really not that it's
actually more like you know what it
reminded me of Fargo actually reminded
me of Fargo or like a Coen Brothers type
of movie they're it's like a crime movie
but it's kind of like this kind of
low-key like black humor yeah
and I actually I ended up really liking
it a lot we actually this is kind of a
cheap because we had a friend that saw
it yeah and he said it's not what you
think
yes he's like it's kind of a comedy like
you can't really tell that from the
trailers so I kind of knew that that's
what it was but yeah it has apparently
like I saw at the end of the thing it's
it's bait it was based on um looks like
a German or a Dutch yeah film I'm not
really sure what it was this is like an
Americanized version but yeah give you a
really really strong like Coen Brothers
Fargo vibe not because it was all set in
the snow and [ __ ] like that too but
similar kind of thing where you know
where there's all this like violent
crime and stuff like that but everybody
acting in it's good the characters are
pretty likable a bunch of unexpected
[ __ ] happens in trying to think of what
else was good about it one thing I like
to do I let you down I liked the very
Edward Gorey touch of every time
somebody got killed in there they would
put like their little ass over a little
Jewish star there's a line going around
the block the line for so yeah like walk
it out there's like this huge line I
couldn't believe it
yeah it's like you know stars look funny
but you know I didn't think it would
have the lines going around the block
they must be doing like a special event
oh yeah
like a special early so um this one
would I recommend it yeah it was
entertaining yeah it's nothing like the
trailer I say that a lot because
trailers are very deceptive well they're
trying to be deceptive I guess so you
kind of don't know what to expect or
also they're trying to market it to a
different audience like I said I feel
like they were trying to market it to
the same people that would have liked
the take in movies but this is really
it's not really the same thing it's
this is more like a Coen Brothers type
movie I got that vibe from it really had
cool guns in it some good shootouts
unexpected [ __ ] it was just funny yeah I
don't want to say it was it was it was
funny but it is weird it's not quite a
comedy it's a gangster movie with a
bunch of funny comedy yeah yeah it's
almost kind of like if a Quentin
Tarantino movie wasn't as over-the-top
yeah
or silly or like I said it's my to me a
Fargo a lot more than anything I've
never seen that so I can yeah it
reminded me of that it was it was like a
similar kind of tone where it just had
these like there's a like hyper violent
[ __ ] like people just like beating the
[ __ ] out of each other Steve found stuff
but then like they were like all these
like really like yeah and like I said
that last scene was hilarious yeah and
you'll build up these characters into
being something real special and they
just kill yeah yeah if you like that
kind of thing if you like kind of black
humor Coen Brothers type stuff that I
would definitely recommend this cuz
that's what this was okay
all right we just got done seeing the
lego movie - I think it's called but a
second the second part yeah we saw the
first part last night we rented it
rented off my xbox I couldn't get
through it is just to the episode the
second one the second one I think was
better than the first one
I actually like the look I like the
person to you but I like this one better
just because it had I like that it has
kind of more Omashu select it does have
like a lot of like Mad Max fury road yes
yeah it's really for kids of course you
know I mean - but you could tell that
adults wrote it with and they put things
in there because they knew that parents
would have to be in there so they you
know they wanted to make it enjoyable
for them - there it's a fantasy it's
about a bunch of little Lego creatures
little Lego creatures and little Lego
characters on this big adventure because
in another dimension the kids are
playing with them yeah and which spoiler
alert if you didn't see the first yeah
yeah they're um they're well made movies
the music is really good the lyrics to
the music it's Kyle
like a half a second and every second
something's happening just wall-to-wall
humor or some kind of wall-to-wall
action which for I think a kid look
gloves that I think they love it it's
just constant something happening for an
adult you know for me it just starts
becoming like too much I mean imagine
it's a 12 pitch
imagine you took a whole bunch of
ecstasy and snorted a whole bunch of
cocaine and then it hit a bunch of
sugary sugary cereal and that the things
constantly bouncing off the roof and
you're just going oh man enough Oh
although this was a little less
like very frenetic oh yeah but like I
said I'd like this one better because I
think one of the things that makes this
movie is the character Rex danger vest
which is I mean he's kind of supposed to
be Kurt Russell it's just be snake but
he's supposed to be like snake like they
don't come out and say that yeah yeah
that's I think who they were modeling it
after this double he didn't have an
eyepatch or nothing no he did kind of
like supposed to that girl Russell yeah
so that's what I was that good yeah but
yeah it's like like I said it is very
over the job yeah but if you like I
think I mean I thought it was fine
particularly all the stuff with Batman
like yeah especially like at the end
when he gets kind of brainwashed and
like he's like cowl it it's a little
white fur cape and [ __ ] yeah it's real
difficult to talk about the plot because
it's all over the place in terms of you
know they're just constantly trying to
entertain you so the plot isn't the main
point of the movie I tell you the truth
I've dozed off a couple times watching
it and when I came back - I didn't miss
anything like it picked it up you know I
know exactly what was going on is that
the first part of it like I said if you
saw the first movie then at the end of
it you see that like Will Ferrell is the
guy's dad was like whoa oh wow the my
sister has to play with Legos too
because now that you're allowed to play
with them so now the little sister comes
down so you know the thing that he's
created which is like a Mad Max fury
road type of situation the Kip older kid
is going on so now the sister comes
taller cutie like little Duplo blocks
and like all her little sparkly [ __ ] and
is like destroying her life kind of and
she comes and takes like a bunch of his
characters and so Emmet the main
character from that main one has to go
into this other dimension like this
sistar system sister do we really have
to go
because it is silly s [ __ ] it just is
but I'll tell you what it is cleverly
written the dialogue all the little
songs the you can tell that they have it
a lot of fun making the movie is just
packed yeah and it's not just every now
and then it's just [ __ ] packed with
them with a lot here and even the
credits have a [ __ ] funny songs and
they're singing about how awesome the
credits are it's a psycho silly yeah
it's supposed to be that way yeah it's a
little ad D so if you don't like that
kind of yeah I don't like it but I
imagine kids that probably love it
anyway I couldn't take it I know I could
you sound like that but like it was less
like that than that person yeah the
first one was just over it's just too
much too much imagine you're eating a
hot fudge sundae and then you like
sprinkle chocolate on chocolate chips on
top of that and then spray chocolate
dust and then put a whole bunch of syrup
you know like maple syrup on top of that
and then you don't manage to see smooth
look and then you put put the sugar bowl
on it just too [ __ ] much man it's too
[ __ ] fast you'll for the towhead [ __ ]
yeah would I recommend it no no and I'd
take these kid to go see it they way
they drive me [ __ ] crazy I go what
about you if you record what you go see
this if you had to pay for this I might
I don't know I I find this kind of stuff
amusing son okay as your prerogative
[Music]